yeah I still am not entirely sure how to
answer um Mark 2:7 and I think it's what
is it John 20:23 in terms of how that
proves that Jesus is God yes okay that
he can forgive sins yeah what's the
what's the objection so I have answer
but what's the
objection uh just that if Jesus can give
the authority to forgive sins to us then
why couldn't the father give that to a
creature as well yeah because I've
explained who said the apostles are
forgiving sins the way Jesus forgave
Jesus said your sins are forgiven you
and he says I authority to say your sins
are forgiven you where do you get the
Apostle said that I showed you that in
the context the way they declared
forgiveness of sin is by you accepting
Jesus then you're forgiven but but if
you reject Jesus then you stand
condemned let's go to John 20 and look
at it again so it's how they went about
forgiving people their
sins okay okay do you want me to start
at 23 or do you want me to start before
that well first read John 2023 and I'm
going to articulate the objection so
people can understand what you're asking
John
20:23 okay if you forgive the sins of
any they are forgiven them if you retain
the sins of any they are retained now
here's the objection we say Jesus is God
because he forgives sins but hold on
Jesus said the apostles can forgive sins
or condemn people for their sins yet
that doesn't prove their God so how to
respond to that so here's how we respond
to that objection number one when Jesus
says your sins are forgiven he does so
by the authority he has as God in Union
with the father and the spirit he can
say I forgive you of your sins because
I'm one with the father and the spirit
and as God I alone have power to forgive
because he's God so the father son
Spirit as the one God they alone can
forgive sins what about the apostles are
they forgiving sins the way Jesus no
because we have to understand how they
went about forgiving sins because Jesus
says whoever sins you're forgiven will
have been forgiven in heaven whoever
sins that you retain meaning anyone you
say they're not forgiven then that means
they're not forgiven in heaven here's
how John 2030-31
the how is important the how go to John
30-31 and truly Jesus did many other
signs in the presence of his disciples
which are not written in this book but
these are written that you may believe
that Jesus is the Christ the son of God
and that believing you may have life in
his name did you catch it he just said
you will have everlasting life if you
believe in Jesus Christ and if you
believe he can says you're forgiven you
have everlasting life now go to John
3:36 and I'm going to show you that's
what Jesus means because he's talking
about the context of sending them forth
to preach the
gospel okay so now John 3es go sorry
yeah he who believes in the son has
everlasting life and he who does not
believe the son shall not see life but
the wrath of God abides on him see
that's what they're doing see that's
that's how they're exercising that
Authority hey believe in Jesus you'll
have everlasting life you'll be forgiven
you don't believe you will be condemned
to hell so now that you've rejected
Jesus then you're going to hell let me
now show you that in Practical Ministry
how they did it go to acts 1346 to
47 so is it the same way the way Jesus
did no because they're not they're not
directly forgiving the sins it's just
through the name of Jesus and they don't
say by our on Earth we do this we're
saying that Jesus authorized us to tell
you you believe in him we can say you're
forgiven you reject him we say you're
condemned you're going to hell so acts
1346 47 what does it say
there then Paul and bar Barnabas grew
bold and said it was necessary that the
word of God should be spoken to you
first but since you reject it and judge
yourselves Unworthy of everlasting life
behold we turn to the Gentiles for so
the Lord has commanded us I have set you
as a light to the Gentiles that you
should be for salvation to the ends of
the Earth so you see what he said you've
now deemed yourself Unworthy of
everlasting life that means you're not
saved you're condemned but why because
you rejected the Gospel of Jesus
Christ okay yeah I see that that makes
so much more sense then you catch it now
now let me show you where John says John
says because you believed in Jesus
you're forgiven go to 1 John 1
7-10 and I'm gonna go back to John 20 in
a
minute okay first John 1 vers 7
but if we walk in the light as he is in
the light we have fellowship with one
another and the blood of Jesus Christ
his son cleanses us from all sin see
that's
it don't rush bro hold on go ahead say
logos with me logos man dude it's like
you're rushing to get to a marathon come
on bro you see what he said if we walk
in the light as he is in the light then
our fellowship is one another and the
blood of Jesus Christ his son cleanses
us from all sins so he just said you're
forgiven yeah why are you forgiven
because you have turned to Christ and
you have fellowship with God and the
blood of Christ cleanses
you now read vers Now read verses 8 to
10 if we say that we have no sin we
deceive ourselves and the truth is not
in us if we confess our sins he's
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness we will forgive you or
he'll forgive
you he is faithful and just to forgive
us our sins so what does he say I
forgive
you he doesn't okay can I keep
going if we say that we have not sinned
we may we make him a liar and his word
is not in US you got it now how they're
pronouncing forgiveness and
condemnation yeah it's not on their own
authority they're just saying because
you believe in Jesus now your sins are
forgiven yep and if you reject him now
you stand condemned you're going to hell
in fact go to John
3:18 John 3:18 he who believes in Him is
is not condemned but he who does not
believe is condemned already because he
has not believed in the name of the only
begotten Son of God end of story buddy
you caught it yeah I see that yeah I got
it I know how to answer that thank you
but now let's go back to the context to
prove that's what Jesus is saying Jesus
saying I'm not going to send you out
with the responsibility of preaching the
gospel the gospel that if someone
believes you can then pronounce they're
forgiven a gospel if they reject and you
can pronounce they are condemned and
remain in their sin let's go back and
see the context John 20 21-
23 John 20 21- 23 go ahead so Jesus said
to them again peace to you as the father
has sent me I also send you when he had
said this you get it I send you what's
the context
now he's saying as the father has sent
me so I also send you I send you to do
what to proclaim the gospel that's the
context of 23 Now read Now read
22 and when he had said this he breathed
on them and said to them receive the
Holy Spirit now here's my challeng see
man dude you are so excited to get this
over with now you're gonna read 22 two
more times
buddy okay and when he had said this he
breathed on them and said to them
receive the Holy Spirit and when he had
said this he breathed on them and said
to them receive the Holy Spirit okay now
if you rush to another passage dial tone
buddy
listen you see what he just did there
you see what he just did
there what did he gave the he breathed
and then gave them the Holy Spirit now
show me a single being besides Jehovah
God that breathes the Holy Spirit upon
anyone yeah no there's not there's not
so then the very verse you quoted John
20:23 if you just read 22 it shows that
Jesus is doing what only God Almighty
does breathe out the Holy Spirit to give
life in this context spiritual life
regeneration how does then 23 show that
Jesus isn't
God yeah it doesn't when you put it in
context it makes so much more sense so
now is that clear now